okay this is a pepper panic saga level
86 walkthrough tutorial
i have a player in a group who's stuck
on the level so
i was going back to play it to see if i
could think of some more things to some
more tips and
i figured i'd just go ahead and make a
video while i was at it
we have a lot of yellow peppers in the
cages
and some red and some green
um not much at the top of the board
so we'll go ahead and make this l-shaped
match down here
go ahead and make another shockwave
match there
now since we have a lot of yellow ones
trapped next to the
statues themselves it'd be nice to make
a couple explosions with yellow to get
those to grow a bit
and it's even better when you get a
shock wave in the cascade while you're
doing that
so strategy wise we're looking for shots
that we can hit these things with
directly
but if we can't find any then we're
trying to grow yellow peppers and
as the other colors start to grow
we'll try to hit the we'll try to get
the ones that are sitting next to the
statues to explode
like these purples they don't really
help us at all so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna go out of my way to try to
explode those
same with the red
the two colors that are most
most grown on the board right now
but it looks like we'll be able to get a
green chain reaction first so
that'll give us a couple hits towards
our statues
and we were able to grow these yellow
peppers in the cages some so that's good
because they can come in handy later
so we gotta we got a decent moment we
didn't get any destruction on the top
but we got a decent amount of damage
and not that many moves so that's a good
way to start
we are going to want to try to
do something about this soon though
all right so there's no shock waves
there
check this road no shock waves
no statue there so nothing though
nothing to aim at so i'll just go ahead
and continue to grow yellow
this is a shockwave match that we
definitely want to take
this looks like it could potentially be
a shockwave match someday
let's see
if we can move this down one then we can
uh
set a shock wave up there but let's see
i don't see a spot where we can make a
match on the outside
this one i guess will make a shockwave
automatically if we make if we match
these that'll pull these two reds and
drop these two red so let's see what
happens when we do that
yeah that'll work
and now we have purple pepper sitting
next to that statue so that changes
things
it seems like a lot of times when you
play this level the color you don't need
is always the one that's ready to
explode
i'm guessing that's just
like selective memory or something but
all right how is there not a shockwave
here
there is
alright so this is um
this is going to hit this it's always
going to move one of our purples
but i don't see any way that we could
actually grow a purple first we just
have to take the immediate shot
we got another purple to fall on its
place so that's good
the yellows aren't
in a hurry to get together but um we can
we can actually kill two birds with one
stone here we can
shoot this yellow one with the purple
shock wave and grow the purples at the
same time so let's see what happens from
that
those are little things that you want to
look for especially whenever like the
peppers are all
grown and
um
and the board gets all chaotic you know
you want to take a little bit of time to
try to you know
search those kinds of matches out
and this looks pretty good
except for that we have all the
different colors so
i think here what we want to do is start
a
panic as fast as possible
but first let's go ahead and take this
statue out
just because
and that actually started the panic
anyway so
oh so close
so now we only have one statue it looks
like we're going to get it
so that's how you um
you work at those statues over there i
mean you won't always get cascades that
turn into pepper panics and and all that
but
if you work
at setting up your um
setting up your shots
and planning out your matches ahead of
time
you'll eventually get to all of them
definitely don't get carried away and
just start exploding stuff over here pay
attention to what colors are next to the
statues
and
look for those gaps and the peppers
that'll give you four-way
shock waves over there
all right i hope it helps if you got any
questions leave a comment
and
thanks